horse racing it's a year-round sport but
no event is as popular as the kentucky
derby and here to show us the ins and
outs of the odds is horse racing expert
bob ike it's great to see you again good
to see you why is betting on the derby
so popular well number one it's a 20
horse field people like big fields
because the the favorite will not get
bet too low so there's a lot of gambling
opportunities people like exotic betting
exactos trifectas super effectives all
the rolling bets so the more horses the
merrier the chances for a big score who
who's the favorite going into tomorrow
it's going to be close between epicenter
and zanden they're the two morning line
favorites right now they're both very
qualified and tough horses is it the
horse or is it the jockey or is it both
it's both the trainers and the mix too
so you have to have the horse you need a
lucky uh fortunate trip you have to have
the right trainer and the right jockey
now tonight
someone like myself i've never really
been on the ponies before you guys you
have a free seminar ramp our casino
what's happening tonight so six o'clock
cascade room dwayne calucci who's the
race and sports book manager and myself
we'll be going over every horse in the
race we'll be showing videotape of the
six major derby prep races we'll be
giving out our picks and betting
strategy as well it's all for free 6 p.m
cascade lounge it'll be food and
beverage and
all of our stuff have a couple cocktails
learn how to bet okay absolutely going
into tomorrow what's something we can
look at what's what are we looking at on
the board
give me some betting 101
basic stuff is a win win place or show
kind of betting a horse finishes first
second or third if you want to step it
up a little bit exact as our horse defen
finishing one two in correct order
i wouldn't if you're a novice i wouldn't
try to get too exotic about it you know
you're going to have 20 to 1 shots in
the race that are live some people pick
names numbers and colors
sometimes it works for them that's not
the way i like to do it but
you know they'll be betting
opportunities galore you said there's a
one-two bet so people actually land the
first place in second place they get
that right yes they get that right and
they don't just play one combination a
lot of people be paying multiple
combinations trifectas are one two three
so yeah you go on and on and there's
just tons of exotic betting but to make
it simple you look at maybe win place
one place and show kind of bets i'm not
gonna hold you to this but is there is
there a long shot out there that you
like
there's so many live long shots you know
there there's this year is a year where
i think maybe eight or ten horses have
legitimate chances there's some names
out there uh i mean the two favorites
and then there's a couple california
horses messier and taba that are tough
there's some florida horses that are
good uh charge it at white a barrio i
mean there's so many things throughout
all the names of the horses
it's really a good crop this year and
it's a competitive race really last
question weather tomorrow is it going to
be raining is that obviously it plays a
factor in who you bet it's supposed to
clear up it did rain there today that
track dries very fast i think it'll be
fine for tomorrow
if you can't make it out we do want you
there for free there's going to be live
streaming also at the
rampartcasino.com so they'll live stream
that uh seminar tonight if you can't
make it we want to see seats in the
house awesome thank you bob you are the
expert in bob's free kentucky derby
seminar it's tonight six o'clock inside
the rampart casino at the cascade lounge
rocky all right